avant d'accepter je sais pas trop quel
prix il veut me donner commençant par
des petits préliminaire poétique
un jour viendra où je ferai le monde
[Applaudissements]
et quand je le ferais l'espère que vous
pire il est mieux là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
uncle de merde pour moi j'ai la même
gueule que d'habitude
gaspiller tout en talents sur les femmes
dalton
là tu pars un peu mouillé salubre if
quand je me lance dans tous ces plaisirs
lorsque j'ai commencé à entendre de la
musique
le monde vibrant va et vient et je tombe
sur la fréquence
j'invite à tence et sereine et puis mes
doigts s'activent
je m' a tourné à 100 milles à l'heure
haymoz surgissent d'une erreur
[Musique]
c'est fini maintenant les bêtises vous
devez publier votre roman si vous
déraillé c'est le retour en prison
bonne chance vers le prochain camp rom
américain bonne chance peut organiser
une telle orgie à mon retour et je vais
inviter ta mère merci monsieur moondog
baissé de découvrir ce qu'il ya sur la
relation illusoire au monde à justin de
suivre mon ami
[Applaudissements]
la dépêche ses avants pilonnent non
parce qu'il a du glaucome dans les deux
yeux
c'est parfait
n'importe quoi pour un ami qui
manquait le ressusciter
je veux tirer avec quelque chose tir
avec celui là
[Musique]